et dans l'actualité également
l'interpellation en algérie des frères
karoui relayée hier par les médias
locaux il s'agit du président du parti
call tounes nabil karoui le député
tunisien ghazi karoui ils tous deux sont
accusés d'avoir pénétré dans la région
de tébessa de manière illégale les deux
frères avaient quitté la tunisie au
lendemain des annonces du président
caixa est de voler le parlement et de
lever l'immunité des députés
les frères karoui ils devraient être
extradés prochainement vers la tunisie
les précisions avec notre correspondant
justement à tunis bassam chedid
c'est une fille qui n'aura duré que
quelques semaines celle des frères
karoui respectivement député président
du parti politique est calme tounes
selon des médias tunisiens et algériens
1 nabil karoui ancien candidat à la
présidentielle tunisienne de 2019 et son
frère le député ghazi karoui se trouvait
dans un appartement du centre ville de
tébessa dans l'est algérien lors de leur
interpellation par la police algérienne
les deux hommes auraient pénétré en
algérie de manière illégale suite au
coup de force du 25 juillet dernier
durant lequel le président sayyed avait
gelé le parlement limogé le chef du
gouvernement est suspendu l'immunité de
tous les députés nabih car oui j'ai de
nouveau rattrapé par la justice avait
été placé en détention provisoire en
août 2019 en pleine campagne
présidentielle une élection pour
laquelle il était favori selon les
sondages il avait été libéré trois jours
avant le premier tour l ancien candidat
ensuite de nouveau été incarcéré en
décembre 2020 pour des affaires de
corruption et de blanchiment d'argent
nabil karoui et son frère devrait être
déféré aujourd'hui devant le procureur
de la république de la willaya de
tébessa en attendant une possible
extradition vers la tunisie